what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today we are
going to be talking about the Titanic or
a submarine that has gone missing so for
those of you that don't know the Titanic
is a ship that sank 112 years ago I
think everyone is pretty much familiar
with the movie The Titanic about a
couple that was on the ship made up of
course but it's based on the unsinkable
ship that 100 years ago was supposed to
you know travel across the ocean ends up
hitting an iceberg and sinks to the
Bottom of the Sea killing a thousand
five hundred people this was an American
Tragedy and it was crazy because
everybody said the ship was Unsinkable
this was impossible it couldn't happen
much to my surprise there are people
that want to find the ship and want to
visit it on the bottom of the ocean so
they actually didn't even locate where
the Titanic was until 8 1985. and the
thing is it's actually really dangerous
it's it's funny because when I was a kid
I I wanted like this was one of the
things I wanted to do it was on my
bucket list until I looked it up and
it's actually supposedly more dangerous
to go to the Titanic than it is to go to
the moon so there's been less than 200
people that have actually successfully
explored the Titanic and there was a
German man in 2021 who actually visited
the Titanic and said that it was a
suicide mission so I personally uh
you know I'm I'm a girl so that sounds
horrible to me but there are people that
pay 250 000 to go see and explore the
Titanic so there was a company called
Ocean Gate and Ocean Gate is a company
that offers people the opportunity to
explore the Titanic and you pay 250 000
and they take you and the thing is there
had been many safety concerns expressed
by people that were supposed to be on
this Mission by people that worked at
the company
um just about how safe this Voyage could
be so a Florida couple actually sued
Ocean Gate for two hundred thousand
dollars accusing them of misleading them
about their trip and refusing to give
them a refund apparently this trip has
been delayed multiple times due to
safety concerns and that sort of thing
the director of the movie Titanic James
Cameron actually called visiting the
Titanic the most unforgiving place on
earth now this is a guy that has visited
the Titanic 33 times you know I I
actually think it's really cool that
people would still want to do it like I
think it shows How brave you know men
are you know as opposed to women women
because I I could not now that they are
investigating this there's more
information coming out so first of all a
former Ocean Gate employee was fired
after raising concerns about Titan which
is the vessel that is going to the
bottom of the ocean so a former employee
of Ocean Gate had raised concerns over
safety quality issue controls regarding
Titan to Ocean Gate executive management
according to court filings he claimed in
August of 2018 that he was wrongfully
fired after flagging worries about the
company's alleged refusal to conduct
critical non-destructive testing of the
experimental design after issues of
quality control with Titan was raised
the filings say Mr Rush asked Mr
Lockridge in to conduct a Quality
Inspection to report The Vessel and
there was actually even and a friend of
one of the missing passengers who pulled
out of the trip due to safety concerns
Chris Brown had paid the deposit to go
on the voyage but said he changed his
mind after becoming concerned about the
quality of the technology and the
materials used in The Vessel he told the
newspapers that despite being one of the
first people to sign up for this trip
the risks were just too high okay so now
we know this company is kind of shady
they were kind of cutting corners and it
also came out that the CEO of the
company admitted to hiring people for
not based on their experience and their
expertise but based off of them being
young and based off of them being a
woman in order to inspire people now
guys this is why there is such a problem
with hiring people for diversity and
inclusion rather than the best people
for the job because this is what
happened he talks about the CEO talks
about hiring people
uh yes I mean when I started the
business one of the things you'll find
there are other sub-operators out there
but they they typically
um have a gentlemen who are ex-military
submariners and they you'll see a whole
bunch of 50 year old white guys
um I wanted our team to be younger to be
inspirational and I'm not going to
inspire a 16 year old to go pursue
Marine technology but a 25 year old uh
you know who's a subpilot or a platform
operator or one of our techs can be
inspirational so we've really tried to
to get
um very intelligent motivated younger
individuals involved because we're doing
things that are completely new we're
taking approaches that are used largely
in the Aerospace industry is related to
safety and uh some of the the
preponderance of checklists things we do
for risk assessments and things like
that that are more Aviation related than
ocean related and we can train people to
do that we can train someone to pile up
the sub we use a game roller so anybody
can drive the sub who actually signed up
for this trip so there's five people
aboard the summary one of the people on
board is actually the vice chairman of
and grow corporation which is a company
that makes food fertilizers and energy
he's also a chairman on Darwin Hercules
corporation which which makes chemicals
and his son who's 19 years old the CEO
of the company and two other people so
the company actually left the submarine
like submerged at one o'clock on Sunday
and at 2 45 so an hour and 45 minutes
into the Expedition they lost contact
now a submarine and the issue was this
is a different type of Technology I'm
not an expert on submarine you know
technology but from what I understand
it's actually a type of Technology where
the only way they'll have power to come
back up is if they have contact with the
ship where a regular submarine mean I
guess it's more self-sufficient so this
was you know a new type of Technology
the crazy thing is it took them eight
hours to notify the Coast Guard knowing
that they only have until about 6 a.m on
Thursday until the ship runs out of
oxygen now another thing that came out
with this company is that the German man
who actually went to the Titanic in 2021
to see the Titanic called The Voyage a
suicide mission saying that parts of the
submarine were literally falling off he
said the first submarine they tried
didn't even work and the second
submarine had to be abandoned the good
news is the Coast Guard is picking up on
a noise that they believe is the Fallen
submarine at least they have a Target
right now because the other issue is
that I guess it is so deep in the ocean
that it's very tough to find so the fact
that they have a sound to actually look
for is a good thing so there's a couple
theories on what could have happened one
thing that could have happened was a
whole breach and essentially that means
that there was a a hole in the submarine
basically they're hoping that didn't
because that the chance of surviving
that is pretty much zero so the good
thing is in this whole situation is the
Coast Guard has heard a banging sound so
they're hoping that they can locate the
submarine and save the people on board
I'm gonna keep you guys posted on this
story let me know what you guys think in
the comments and would you go visit the
Titanic if you had the chance I I think
this is crazy but it goes back to
showing that woke companies hiring
people for diversity rather than being
the best people for the job and the
ramifications that has I will keep them
in our prayers hopefully they can locate
the submarine and I'll keep you guys
posted on the story like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time